the grudge is many things but subtle
ain't one of them
so you probably didn't get too lost
along the way but just in case here's
everything you need to know to make
sense of the grudge's shocking ending
beware spoilers abound The Grudge tells
its story out of order saving the big
reveals for when they will deliver the
biggest emotional punch telling the
story chronologically isn't as
interesting but it is necessary to
understand the ending in 2004 Fiona
Landers returns home from Japan where
she worked as a caretaker in a cursed
house unfortunately while fiona is happy
to be reunited with her husband Sam and
her daughter Melinda the joy doesn't
last the curse has followed Fiona home
to 44 Wrayburn drive where driven mad by
the apparitions she sees she drowns
Melinda and stabs Sam then takes her own
life
shortly afterwards married real estate
agents Peter and Nina Spencer unaware
that the Landers have been murdered try
to sell the Rayburn house Peter goes
inside the house but Nina who's pregnant
doesn't the curse attaches itself to
Peter who stabs Nina in their kitchen
before drowning himself in their tub in
2005 faith and William Matheson move
into the house so that faith who has
cancer can be closer to her doctors both
faith and Williams see ghosts but while
William isn't too worried faith loses
her mind by the time Lorna moody an
assisted suicide attendant comes by to
help faith die with dignity
faith is completely gone faith murders
William and cuts off her own fingers
Lorna flees but sees a vision of Sam
Landers while driving and crashes her
car her body isn't found for months this
is where detective Muldoon enters the
picture
[Music]
I'm detective Muldoon in 2006 Muldoon
moves to town just a few months after
losing her husband forcing her to raise
her son Burke alone her new partner
detective Goodman has a few tragedies in
his past to his original partner Wilson
became obsessed with the house at 44
Rayburn Drive after investigating the
Landers killings and eventually shot
himself he survived and is now
institutionalized most importantly
however Goodman isn't haunted by the
curse see he never stepped inside the
Rayburn house it gave him a weird
feeling so he stayed away and so he's
free of it's supernatural tormentors
well you never go into that place
something never felt right about the
original grudge hinted at the idea and
sequels made it explicit but the reboot
makes it clear the jus own or grudge
will infect anyone who steps into the
location where the curse lives stay
outside and you're fine
Muldoon doesn't know this though so she
enters the house while investigating
Lorna Moody's death almost immediately
the Landers family begins haunting her
afraid that the visions will make her
hurt Burke
Muldoon decides to burn the Rayburn
house to the ground
hopefully ending the curse the house is
destroyed but as the final scene shows
it doesn't do much the länder spirits
are still around there's one big
question that The Grudge doesn't
explicitly answer and it's a big one
what horrific act of violence created
the curse the 20/20 film begins with the
curse already active fiona has already
been infected in the opening scene when
she returns home her family's death is a
foregone conclusion to find the
explanation you actually need to go back
to the 2004 version of The Grudge yep
that's right
the Japanese house where fiona works is
the same one featured in the Sarah
Michelle Gellar flick that kicked off
the American leg of the franchise in the
2004 movie we discovered that the curse
was born when Tokyo psyche learned that
his wife kaya chol was in love with her
college professor in a fit of jealousy
Tokyo murdered kaya CO and their son
Toshio creating the curse The Grudge
reboot doesn't spell this out but the
clues are there perhaps the most telling
one
is that detective Wilson says that he's
talked to a detective named Nicola who
investigated a murder at the house where
Fiona was working that's the Japanese
detective who appeared in the original
grudge the house and the opening scene
also looks a lot like the one in the
2004 movie and the film's end credits
confirm that the ghost fiona sees in the
garbage bag is indeed kya co the
antagonist of the first three grudge
movies given that the 2004 grudge and
the 2020 grudge stick to a similar
formula it's possible that the reboot
sequels will too if so here's what you
can expect like the 2020 version of the
grudge the grudge 2 takes place between
2004 and 2006 in the earlier timeline
Karen's sister Aubrey travels to Japan
to bring Karen home and ends up infected
by the curse and dying for her efforts
in the 2006 story three girls break into
the psyche house on a dare to die but
another haunted by Aubrey's spirit and
kya kool returns to the United States
bringing the curse to Chicago in The
Grudge 3 the sole surviving victim from
the previous movie dies attracting the
attention of Cayucos sister now cool now
Cole moves to America and tries to
exorcise Tokyo psyche spirits hoping to
end the curse once and for all the
results are mixed Nalco is killed during
the process and while the exorcism is
successful now uncle's murder sparks a
whole new grudge starting the process
all over again on the other hand the
grudge reboot introduces enough new
ideas to the mythology that a potential
sequel could go in a different direction
the revamp makes it clear that the curse
can spread not just from person to
person but from location to location the
psyche house might have been where it
started but the Wrayburn house ends up
just as dangerous if Muldoon's house is
now another home base for the curse it
wouldn't be too surprising we don't know
if Muldoon died at the end of the movie
or not but the final shot of the movie
ominously lingers on our house the house
is filmed similarly to the Rayburn house
- with its street address number 14
featuring prominently in the frame it
could be that the Landers family
relocated to Muldoon's property when the
Rayburn house burned down
or maybe the town now has to ghostly
hotspots either way if Burke asks your
kid to stop by for a sleepover
you should probably say no check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff for coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]